can I say there can I say back to the
polls just now you guys you guys invited
us here you asked for this
hey everybody we are the try guys we are
here at EC live to announce that we are
going to be featured creators at VidCon
this year July 10th to 13th get your
tickets now we're coming it's gonna be
awesome
some things we're doing today the old
beard the new vid the somewhat old and
kind of move is yesteryear bye guys test
legal alcohol limit the first in many
videos that are like this is us testing
to see if our videos could be more than
try on so I think this was definitely a
step toward us knowing that this was a
big idea that we could explore as a show
this was really a turning point on our
journey to really formalizing it as a
series so ugiy made this video and did a
phenomenal job on it stylistically I
think this really set the tone for a lot
of what the try guys became Eugene was
planning on making this video for months
it predated the try guys he was working
on this and then after we had made a few
videos together we kind of just took him
aside one day were like you're gonna
recast this give me up for that stupid
yeah cuz I'm you know actually part of
this culture so it was always in ewa
table for me I think Ned was probably
the most nervous yeah yeah he had never
even been to a drag show I was still not
even comfortable being a try guy yeah a
lot of people think that we still just
jump all four of us headfirst into
something it was very clear that the
other three guys would not tuck it's
part of being a drag queen where you
shove your balls into your body like
there's cavities and they descend funny
I don't know when you don't have any
more in your mouth if you jump into a
really cool pool as a guy sometimes your
balls feel like they kind of go up a
little bit yeah that's where they
descended from so drag queens shove them
up there and then take their and I say
okay they're back to there when I say
back to the poles and that's how to
create the feminine illusion just know
you guys you guys invited us here you
asked for the hips
bye guys try acupuncture I never really
wanted to try it but I was curious about
it are you struggling watching yeah I
avoided watching this one because it was
so but you're not whole thing yet no
sometimes we don't see it until it comes
out when in my face like that he's a
little squeamish it was in my ear
are you serious that was all about
oh my god you're seeing it here first
Wow and then watching his video wait
what's this what's this this is my face
watching no no no no no it's so that's
in your eyeball it was very close
this is probably a top five all-time try
got video now this is I think what a
mutual favorite for all of us right a
lot of people have this assumption that
we sort of are already 100% behind
everything we do or we're already super
comfortable with an idea I can say with
confidence that cooking based stuff two
of us were not actually very interested
you'll have to guess at home with two
issues with she's actually probably the
most controversial video in try guys
history internally we try to not make
all of our videos competitions it's not
what it's about it's about trying and
learning and being against yourself but
this is a video that had a winner and I
will say that internally we still have
disagreements about who should have won
doesn't know how you possibly could
think that Zack mypie won by the
expertise of a pie maker or is a
high-end pie making way that's what she
does
Wow I'm sorry you can't just swallow the
fact that your pie was unsolvable
if I was a soup Eugene try guys meet
Ned's baby we've gone through a lot
together I mean when we started making
these videos we didn't know where it was
gonna go to be totally honest we weren't
even that close of friends yet but we
started making these videos as a test
and it was really the audience that
decided there was something there that
we should keep pushing and seeing if
this could be a series over the last
five years it's really developed
organically and in that process we've
become much closer than friends much
closer than coworkers where we're a
family now we're brothers that zach oh
that was so poetic
thanks man also we like taking our pants
off on camera something we've always
wanted to do but have not been able to
do is go to space so if NASA is watching
and you can figure out some way to send
civilians to space we would really like
to look at the earth well since we can't
go to space I guess the next best thing
is going to VidCon 2019 this world
that's the new official slogan maybe you
should say more enthusiastically I was a
little driving with my mic there and
gave us a nice
[Music]